hi good morning and good afternoon
everyone
welcome to today's webinar titled
cracking cellular metabolism
i'm andrea klein of labruts and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is being
sponsored by agilent
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is intended to
be interactive so we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do this you just type them into the
ask a question box and click send
it's helpful if you address each
question to a specific speaker
we will be answering as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation you can also
click
on the ask a question box located on
that far left of your screen
i'll now introduce today's speakers
they're both with agilent technologies
we have dr mark sartain lcms application
scientist
and dr genevieve van de bitner scientist
at agilent research laboratories
for a complete biography on our speakers
you can visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen but dr van der
bitner i'll now turn it over to you to
begin
welcome and good morning this morning's
webinar will cover
a new comprehensive workflow for
cracking cellular metabolism
from sample prep to data collection and
analysis
the first portion of the talk will
introduce a new mammalian cell sample
prep workflow
that uses a room temperature metabolism
quenching solution
and solid phase extraction to provide
metabolite and lipid fractions
from individual cell samples
after introducing this new dual
metabolite plus lipid
sample prep workflow mark and i will
share data from the application of this
sample prep workflow
to the analysis of the cellular response
to drug treatment
this will be presented in the context of
a broader and comprehensive sample prep
data collection and data analysis
workflow
agilent has a long history of working
with the metabolomics community dating
back to the first
international metabolomic society
meeting in 2004
we've worked with the community to
develop tools to facilitate metabolomics
research
as you can see the road from then to now
includes many innovations in the
metabolomics field
both software and hardware from the mass
profiler professional
statistical software package to the
metabolomics dmrm metabolite data
analysis database
to the bravo metabolomics platform
automated plasma sample preparation
workflow
the agilent commitment to continued
leadership and innovation in
metabolomics should be clear from our
extensive metabolomics portfolio
new additions to this extensive
portfolio are increasing the number of
comprehensive
end-to-end workflows available including
the dual metabolite plus lipid cell
workflow we will be presenting today
this comprehensive dual workflow takes
advantage of a new
cell sample preparation workflow the
latest agilent hilic z
column and the 6546
lcms system as well as the latest data
analysis software
including lipid annotator profinder 10
and mass profiler professional 15.
when combined these sample prep data
collection
and data analysis solutions make a
powerful comprehensive workflow
that allows for the cracking of cellular
metabolism
the first portion of this webinar will
focus on the new
dual metabolite plus lipid sample prep
workflow
one of our main goals for development of
a dual metabolite plus lipid workflow
for cell sample omics analyses was to
make a workflow that could be automated
however there are a few steps in the
typical cell sample prep workflow that
are difficult to automate
the first difficult to automate step is
the initial step in the workflow
the quick metabolism quenching of the
cells wherein
interconversion of metabolites via
enzymatic activity is halted
commonly this step uses cold liquids
such as liquid nitrogen
which can be dangerous to handle
manually especially when one is in a
hurry to quickly stop metabolism
these cold liquids are also incredibly
hard to handle and store
on an automated robotic system which
prevents automation of the workflow
after metabolism is quenched the
molecular components of the cells such
as proteins
metabolites and lipids are extracted
and for multi-omics analyses different
fractions of the cells are separated
for more facile analysis via lcms
this fractionation is commonly
accomplished via liquid liquid
separations
where polar metabolites favor an aqueous
phase proteins precipitate out
and lipids favor an organic phase
although effective
liquid liquid extractions are very
tricky to precisely separate
both manually and when automated
to overcome the challenges of cold
liquid metabolism quenching
we have developed a room temperature
method for lysine mammalian cells and
quickly quenching metabolism
using trifluoroethanol this room
temperature quenching method improves
workflow safety
reduces workflow complexity and enables
easy handling
of the quenching solution by automated
liquid handlers
to overcome the difficulty of separating
the liquid layers of liquid liquid
separations we have developed a solid
phase
extraction method this extraction method
utilizes the captiva emr lipid plate to
separate polar metabolites and lipids
for downstream
intra-sample multi-omics analyses it is
possible to automate these solid phase
extraction workflow steps
on the bravo liquid handler
this diagram outlines the first major
component of the new
dual metabolite plus lipid cell sample
prep workflow
cell lysis and metabolism quenching
initially
cells must be removed from the media in
which they are growing to isolate
intracellular metabolites
after media removal the cells can
optionally be washed with buffers like
pbs
to further remove extracellular
metabolites
since cell washing can cause leakage of
some metabolites
and increases time before quenching some
prefer to skip the wash step
next the quenching and cell lysis
solution is added
in this case room temperature 50
trifluoroethanol
in water the cells are mixed with this
solution to expedite the metabolism
quentin process
so how do we know that metabolism is
actually quenched
we can add a carbon-13 labeled
metabolite
like ubiquitously labeled carbon-13
glutamine
to the quentin buffer and monitor its
conversion to downstream metabolites
bicellular enzymes
since carbon-13 labeled metabolites have
greater mass
than their endogenous counterparts lcms
analysis can be used to monitor
these compounds in these samples
in this case carbon labeled glutamine is
first converted into carbon-label
glutamate before entering the tca cycle
when an effective quenching reagent has
been added to the cells
like 50 tfe the conversion of carbon
labeled glutamine into downstream
metabolites is stopped
this graph demonstrates this well on the
left
cell lysate from cells that have not had
their metabolism quenched
show a high conversion of labeled
glutamine into labeled glutamate
both a cold quench and our room
temperature tfe quench
prevent the conversion of labeled
glutamine to labeled glutamate
indicating metabolism has been
efficiently quenched there is a small
amount of measurable labeled glutamate
in the quench samples
this is equivalent to the background
level of labeled glutamate from control
samples
not containing cells
after cell lysis and quenching the cell
lysate is next
separated into metabolite and lipid
fractions separation of these fractions
improves the lcms analysis of the
samples by making it possible to target
the separation of unique compound
classes
during liquid chromatography this gives
improved separations and increases the
number of compound identifications
furthermore removal of lipids from the
polar metabolite analysis
helps increase column lifetime to avoid
the difficulty of hard to automate
liquid liquid separations we have used
the captiva emr lipid plate to complete
a solid phase
separation of proteins metabolites and
lipids
as shown in this diagram the captiva emr
plate contains a solid sorbent
that specifically binds lipids
containing acyl hydrocarbon chains
and polar head groups this orbit does
not have an affinity
for metabolites that do not have
hydrocarbon chains
we initially prepare the sample by
adding an organic solvent to form a
protein precipitate
then when we add the sample to the
captiva emr lipid plate the protein
precipitate is caught on a filter above
the emr
sorbent the polar metabolites flow
through the sorbent
and the soluble lipids are captured on
the sorbent
thus the polar metabolites are collected
in the plate flow through
and can be dried and reconstituted prior
to lcms analysis
the lipids are then eluded from the
captiva emr plate using
a relatively hydrophobic aleutian
solvent
thus metabolites and lipids are
separated and collected from each
individual sample
during the development of this workflow
some optimization was done to increase
metabolite recovery
it was found that increasing the water
content from 18
to 50 percent for a mixture of
metabolite standards
prior to passing them through the
captiva emr lipid plate
could increase the fraction of
metabolite standards that made it
through the plate
improvements in recoveries were
particularly good for bulkier
amphiphilic
and more hydrophobic molecules when
increasing the water content of the
samples
we wanted to maintain protein
precipitation as much as possible
to accomplish this proteins are first
precipitated by an organic solvent
then the water is added second to a
final content of 50 percent
this provides significantly larger
amounts of precipitate
than when the organic solvent and water
are added together
thus maintaining a protein precipitate
level similar
to that obtained by adding an organic
solvent alone
you may now be wondering what the
metabolite recoveries look like for this
workflow
when the cell sample matrix is present
to test this we took frozen cell pellets
each containing 1 million cells and
prepared them using our dual metabolite
plus lipid workflow
then to monitor recoveries we added a 13
labeled metabolite mixture
to the samples before or after
they were passed through the captiva emr
lipid plate
the percent recovery for each carbon 13
labeled metabolite was measured
by dividing the metabolite peak area
from the pre-spike sample
by the peak area from the post-spike
sample
for this experiment there were six
pre-spiked
and six post bike samples and we
compared the dual
metabolite plus lipid workflow to a
liquid extraction workflow
samples were analyzed by lcms to find
the carbon 13 labeled metabolite peaks
here are the plotted recoveries for the
carbon 13 labeled metabolites
monitored with this experiment on the
left are results
from the dual metabolite plus lipid
workflow
and on the right are results from the
liquid extraction workflow
overall the dual workflow provides
excellent recoveries
and also has a lower variability or a
lower
average standard deviation than the
liquid extraction workflow
thus although the dual workflow can
provide access to both metabolite and
lipid fractions
it can also be used to obtain great and
consistent recoveries for investigations
focused on polar metabolites
next we looked at the lipid extraction
performance for the dual
metabolite plus lipid workflow in this
case we had six
sample replicates for both the dual
workflow and a liquid liquid extraction
workflow
lipids were extracted using both
workflows and dried
and reconstituted for lcms analysis
the data files were then analyzed using
lipid annotator
profinder and mass profiler professional
to find the annotated lipids extracted
by each workflow
this is a heat map from mass profiler
professional that shows the
approximately
200 lipids found in negative mode lcms
for the dual metabolite plus lipid
workflow and the liquid liquid
extraction
workflow note the same lipids were found
during data analysis
across the two workflows additionally
ninety percent of the peaks found in the
liquid liquid method
are present in the dual metabolite plus
lipid method
with a peak abundance that is at least
fifty percent of the peak abundance of
the liquid liquid extraction method
overall this indicates that the lipids
normally found with liquid liquid
extraction
are still found with the dual metabolite
plus lipid workflow
additionally the dual workflow is also
easier to perform manually
and much easier to automate
as i mentioned in the beginning the main
reason for developing a room temperature
metabolism quenching method
and a solid phase extraction method for
separating metabolites
lipids and proteins was to make a
metabolite plus lipid sample prep
workflow for cells
that was easily automated while we
haven't yet automated the cell lysis and
quenching portion of this workflow
the use of room temperature tfe for cell
lysis and metabolism quenching
decreases the workflow complexity even
when performed manually
we have automated on the agilent bravo
liquid handler
the separation and collection of
metabolites and lipids using the captiva
emr lipid solid phase extraction plate
this automation provides access to
intra-sample multi-omics
analysis through hands-free sample prep
the automated method can be set up to
allow processing
of 8 to 96 samples at a time by using 1
to 12 columns of a 96 wall plate
now that we have covered the new dual
metabolite plus lipid sample prep
workflow
we will demonstrate use of this workflow
in the context of a comprehensive
end-to-end sample prep data collection
and data analysis workflow
wherein we monitor the cellular response
to drug treatment
to demonstrate our comprehensive
end-to-end workflow we use a well-known
and well-studied cancer arthritis model
wherein the k-562 leukemia cancer cell
line
is treated with methotrexate a drug used
both as a cancer
and arthritis therapeutic
although well studied the mechanism of
action for methotrexate is still
incompletely understood
recent studies have indicated that
methotrexate causes modest decreases in
relative abundances of multiple lipid
classes
and both relative increases and
decreases in key metabolites
thus we aim to apply the dual metabolite
plus lipid
sample prep workflow in combination with
lcms
data acquisition and data analysis to
the assessment of the impact
of methotrexate treatment on k-562
leukemia cells
the results were compared to a recently
published study
by funk and colleagues
the comprehensive mammalian cell
workflow we used to assess methotrexate
treatment of k-562 cells
included a variety of agilent technology
solutions
including the described dual metabolite
plus lipid
sample prep workflow sample analysis
using
helix z liquid chromatography the
lc qtof and analysis using mass center
software
including lipid annotator profinder and
mass
profiler professional
the results of the comprehensive
workflow are metabolite and lipid
annotations
an analysis of whether there are
significant changes to the metabolite or
lipid upon methotrexate treatment
and an analysis of the specific
metabolic pathways
that are impacted by methotrexate
to complete the methotrexate treatment
of k-562 cells we first divided the
cells into eight separate flasks
and grew the cells over two splits to
make eight distinct biological
replicates on the day of treatment
cells from each biological replicate
were split to a density of four
times ten to the fifth cells per
milliliter
half the replicates were treated with
one micromolar methotrexate
the other half of the biological
replicates were treated with
a saline vehicle after 24 hours of
treatment
cells from each biological replicate
were counted
and four aliquots each containing one
million cells
were transferred from each biological
replicate to a microfuge
tube for processing via the
comprehensive end-to-end workflow
the methotrexate treatment very clearly
prevented growth of the k562 cells
as cells treated with methotrexate had
the same cell count after treatment
as before treatment while untreated
cells roughly doubled over the same
time period
although growth was impacted by
methotrexate there did not appear to be
changes in cell size or morphology
now that i have described the biological
experimental design for this
comprehensive workflow
proof of principle study mark will
describe the sample prep
sample analysis and data analysis of the
samples
thank you genevieve and thank you
everyone again for joining us today
okay i'll now pick up where genevieve
left off she just described the sample
study design in terms of cell culture
and drug treatment
the idea here was to use those harvested
cell samples and immediately perform the
room temperature quenching
and then proceed with the automated dual
metabolic plus lipid workflow
just described so we did this dual
workflow
we could collected the metabolites dried
and stored at -80 to await
analyses we sequentially then eluded the
lipids from the captiva emr plate
dried and later reconstituted with
appropriate lcms solvent for lipid
analysis
and so i'd first like to focus on the
lip analysis with you
walk through with you that process and
discuss some of those results
this is just a high level slide showing
the major steps i'll describe for our
targeted libidolux workflow
and i'm just highlighting here some new
features if you're already familiar with
these products
we start with acquisition on our newest
qtof platform which i'll introduce in
the next slide
then really at the core of liponomics
analysis is our lipid annotator software
for fast and comprehensive lipid
annotation we go on to feature
extraction with profinder
and we end with new specific support for
lipidumx and our mass profiler
professional software
let's first talk more in depth about
data acquisition now last year agilent
introduced a new lc qtof
the 6546 so the 6546 delivers the
industry best combination of resolution
and dynamic range designed to meet the
challenges of metabolomics research
there is no longer a need to select high
resolution or extend a dynamic range
mode
with the 6546 there is only one mode
that provides these advantages
simultaneously
the 6540 fix is also the first q-top to
have an isotopic fidelity specification
which is key to both metabolite
identification and to qualitative flux
analysis
simply put the 6546 is ideal for
metabolomics analysis
regarding the performance on the right
is a figure showing interest
dynamic range from the same flow
injection study
here the carbon-13 enrich e coli spiked
with carbon-13
c2 suctionate with three technical
replicates is overlaid
despite the four-order difference in
intensities mass accuracy and resolution
are maintained
and allow precise determination of both
abundant and low-level peaks
within the same spectrum this is
especially important when measuring
complex matrices with high throughput
approaches such as flow injection
analysis
so tough technology is an excellent
choice for discovery metabolomics
because it provides high resolution high
mass accuracy
and outstanding isotope ratio fidelity
and maintains its performance even its
acquisition rate increases
to determine the ability of the 6546 to
maintain mass accuracy and resolution at
different acquisition rates
we assess the performance for different
metabolites at acquisition rates from 1
to 50 hertz
the results shown here are for
sustaining acid as a scene on the left
there is no significant change in
performance
being able to acquire results
independent of acquisition rate
accommodates high throughput high speed
chromatography
or chromatic chromatographic liquids can
be very narrow
so regarding chromatography for this
application we chose the 1260 infinity 2
prime lc system
and we see several benefits with this
system the 1260 flux pump has been
designed to offer the 4 channel
flexibility of a quaternary pump
while matching the gradient and mixing
performance of a binary pump
it also offers an 800 bar pressure limit
which met the requirements for the two
types of applications
i'll discuss today including separation
of polar metabolites by hylic
and even separation of lipids by reverse
phase chromatography
for lipid data acquisition here we have
a 19 minute reverse phase chromatography
method
that is well suited for plasma tissues
and cells of eukaryotic origin
shown that a typical total ion
chromatograms in positive and negative
ion mode for the k-562 cells
we use in a study now given the
diversity of lipids not surprisingly
these lcms chromatograms are very
complex
but with advanced untargeted molecular
feature finding software
we can pull out thousands of compounds
from these data files shown here as
overlaid extracted compound
chromatograms
an overarching goal of this particular
lcms method was to capture as much of
the lipodome as possible
in terms of both chromatography and data
acquisition
and so with careful choice of mobile
phases with a single reverse phase
based method we can cover most of the
major polar and nonpolar lipid classes
present in a typical cellular lipid
extract
shown here is a positive imo
chromatogram with overlaid compounds
where we are covering many lipid classes
from the smaller polar lysophospholipids
to the late eluting and very hydrophobic
tricycle cereals and cholesterol esters
now moving away from data acquisition
and onto database creation
agilent mass in our lipid annotator is
new software to support liponomics
and like profinder it is provided free
of charge to absolute customers
lipid annotator supports both lcq tough
and imq tough msms data
lipid antenna software uses multiple
scoring algorithms and a modified
theoretical lipid library to annotate
msms spectra based on installico
spectral matching
this theoretical library is a modified
and extended version of
lipid blast containing half a million or
so
theoretical cutoff lipid spectra
note that splash lipidomic standard from
avanti has been added to the database
and lipped annotator
to support lipid class normalization in
the downstream analysis
i think a really attractive feature is
that the software is designed to not
over annotate lipid features by
providing only a level of structural
information
supported by the msms picture
the feature view shown here allows the
user to get an overview of the results
the feature table contains all features
with associated msms spectra that were
found in the project
there is a configurable feature plot
where results can be displayed as
abundance versus retention time
abundance versus m or z or m or z versus
retention time
this allows for our quality assessment
of the annotation results
in the figure shown the plot is
configured to display retention time on
the x
axis and m or z on the y axis only
annotated lipids are shown and they are
colored by lipid class
the pie chart shows the number of lipids
annotated for each lipid class
so the match details tab provides a more
detailed view for examination of each
lipid match
the lipid sum composition table contains
information for each annotated lipid
some composition includes elliptic class
total number of carbons and the total
number of double bonds
the lipid constituent table provides
possible r group matches for a given sum
composition
the lipid constituent table includes the
abundance percent score
for each possible constituent and if one
constituent can be clearly distinguished
it will be reported as a dominant
constituent
the mirror plot shows the observed msms
spectra on the top
and the in silico database msms spectra
on the bottom
for each selected lipid constituent
so let's step back to data acquisition
for a moment and discuss a concept
now to create the amrt database for the
lipid profiling workflow
we need to acquire msms data on the qtof
as many of you know comprehensive data
dependent lcm sms analysis
provides high quality msms however this
mode can only select a limited number of
precursors in a given time
so low abundant peaks may be missed
editor of msms
automatically does multiple injections
and excludes previously selected
precursors on a rolling basis
in the example shown on the left only
three precursors are selected to
simplify the graphic
on the first injection the top three
precursors are selected for msms
then these are excluded on the second
injection allowing lower
precursors to be selected so how well
does this work for lipids
the box plots of feature abundances
correspond to annotated lipids from
three sequential interval msms
injections
as would be expected we observed that
the mean peak abundance of triggered
lipid precursors decreased across the
first three injections of lipid extract
so how does this compare to conventional
auto msms
the figure on the right shows comparison
between the two modes
with repeat injections in conventional
auto msms mode
only a small increase in annotated
lipids is observed
in contrast hitter of ms-ms shows a
significant increase in the number of
annotated lipids
the number of injections done for msms
depends on the complexity of the sample
and the chromatography for our
cell-based study we determined five
iterative injections were sufficient
okay so here we have the results of a
single pooled k-562 lipid extract that
represents
the 32 samples this single sample was
analyzed by intervams ms
these figures show lipid annotated
results for positive and negative ion
modes
for each ionization mode five iterative
msms data files were acquired and
analyzed
lipid features are colored by lipid
class corresponding to the pie charts
where the number of annotated lipids are
shown as percentages
there are 271 lipids annotated across
the five
positive imo data files and 536 lipids
in negative ion mode
while there are some lipid classes that
ionize in both polarities there are of
course
lipid classes that ionize in only one
mode
this highlights the need in lipidomics
to analyze samples in both modes
we were a bit surprised to see the
larger number of annotations in negative
ion mode
compared to positive this is in contrast
to plasma and lit tissue extracts where
we've seen a larger number observed in
positive ion mode
i would speculate that the low number of
neutral lipids in cells and a large
diversity of phospholipids contribute to
the differences we see here
the lipid annotated results were
exported to a custom personal compound
database and library known as a pcdl
containing accurate masses spectra and
retention times
ie and amrt database separate positive
and negative ionization mode databases
were created for subsequent analysis of
ms-1 data
the resulting pcdl databases can be
examined and also edited in agilent pcdl
manager
alright so how do we leverage this
database
really have two workflows untargeted and
targeted
now with both workflows the database is
used to annotate ms-1 lipid profiling
data
using ms-1 data is a preferred approach
as collecting data in this mode
ensures adequate sampling of the
chromatographic peak even with fast
chromatography
it also improves the quantitative
results of the pendulum's experiments
in the untargeted workflow significant
features are queued against the database
to look for hits at the end of the
process
for the sake of time today we're going
to walk through the results for the
targeted workflow
shown on the right and i like to think
of this as a data driven workflow
as a database is used as criteria for
targeted feature extraction
to only extract annotated lipids from
ms-1 data
again using the same chromatography that
was used for database creation
in the end those annotated results can
be imported into agilent mass profiler
professional software
for chemometric analysis as we'll show
next
now as i mentioned profinder software
was used to do targeted feature
extraction
on the ms-1 datasets the profinder
results were imported into mass profiler
professional for statistical analysis
where separate experiments were created
for positive and negative ion modes
after normalization and baselining the
resulting pca plots for both polarities
were overall similar
without filtering of entities that is
keeping all compounds
the results showed tight clustering of
the biological replicates within each
condition
and demonstrated clear differences
between mtx and vehicle
if you remember there were four replicas
each from four cell culture plates in
each condition
which are indicated by symbols we didn't
see a separation here based on cell
culture plate
and this indicates us that really the
drug treatment appeared to be the
dominant variable responsible for the
separation
one of the nice newer features of mpp
allows creation of lipid matrix plots
or some would describe as heat maps this
type of plot shows differences between
the methotrexate treatment
and control where each row is a lipid
class and each column is the average of
four replicates from each cell culture
plate
the abundance scale is read for high and
blue for low
clear differences were visually observed
across the big classes
in agreement with the findings of the
paper we are referencing ceramides were
increased in the
methotrexate treated cells while the
reverse train was observed for
phosphatidyl inositols
now for any particular lipid class we
can dig deeper and view the lipid
matrix plot for the individual annotated
lipids
here is the lipid matrix plot for
phosphatidylstols
and in this case all individual sample
replicates are shown as columns
and the individual annotated pi lipids
are shown in rows
in this case we can see a clear trend
where phosphonolostal lipids with
relatively low number of carbons
in their sterified acyl chains found to
be decreased in methotrexate treated
cells
in mvp it's useful to look at the data
in different ways
and here we're showing a more
traditional volcano plot using a t-test
to pull apart differences between the
methotrexate drug treatment versus the
vehicle control
there are 63 significant features that
pass the cut off shown
we had to use a fairly modest full
change value of 1.5
and indeed the authors of the paper we
are comparing against also found that
lipid changes were fairly muted compared
to some of the polar metabolite levels
we'll discuss in a bit now that paper
also showed that a phosphatidylstol with
some composition 32
0 was the most significant lipid and
indeed we found the same lipid in our
short list of lipids
that decrease with mtx treatment which
is again
in agreement with their findings but
with our approach in this instance we
are able to go beyond some composition
annotation
because there is msms spectral evidence
at the olympic constituent level
for the nature of the esterified fatty
acids for a bird's
view of the data we can perform
unsupervised hierarchical clustering
here we are switching over to the
positive ion mode experiment
we can already see that the biological
replicas group together well with
respect to drug treatment
but i think what is really interesting
is a zoom in on a group of entities with
notable differences
here we see that a group of acyl
carnitine lipids group together
in an unsupervised manner and are
increased with methotrexate treatment
now this lipid class was not reported by
the authors as isocarnitines were not
targeted with their methodology
so this new finding we are showing here
seems to be the direct result of
initially creating a database
based in an unrestricted manner for
iterative msms data in the pooled sample
will search against the very large
insuligo library
ok i'd like to switch gears now and
introduce the metabolite workflow
you could already see from this slide
that many of the products are shared
with the lipid workflow
and we introduced a few slides back in
terms of software
some key differences here include the
mechanism of compound annotation
and you also see we can really begin to
leverage biological pathways
with pathway architect software
so if you remember this slide we had
originally intended to show you today
results from the dried metabolite
extracts prepared with a dual workflow
however due to covet 19 we were not able
to get into the lab to run and analyze
the samples
instead i'd like to show you results
from a small substitute data set we had
previously acquired
this data set addresses the same biology
we've already introduced
and i hope can serve the purpose of
walking through the metabolomics data
analysis workflow with you
let me briefly describe this data set as
there are some differences from the
experiment we had originally planned
and also some limitations first the
chromatography method is different than
the highly optimized helix z gradient
that i'll show in the next slide
the data set was acquired on the 6545
qtof in negative ion mode only
and with ms-1 data only the lack of msms
data here means we can only go so far
in the analysis as we can't quite get
the confidence table identification with
this dataset
while we do have the same cell line and
drug treatment the concentration
and duration of the treatment differed
from that we used in the lipid
experiment
there are only three biological
replicates each and a crude metabolite
extraction protocol we used to use to
extract one tablet
instead of the automated dual workflow
we've been describing
however despite these limitations a
course look at the total ion
chromatograms shown on the right
indicate that the replicates overlay
nicely and some subtle differences can
already be
observed from the tic
as many of you know good chromatography
for polar metabolites has always been a
challenging area
so in 2018 agilent introduced a new
helix z column that is a novel sweater
ionic phase
and is designed to be stable at extended
ph it's also designed to be used with
low buffer concentrations which enhances
ms signal
in addition to introducing the hilux z
column agilent also introduced the
infinity lab deactivator additive
this additive improves detection and
peak shape for some metal-sensitive
metabolites that can be problematic
otherwise
importantly for metabolomics the ability
to run at low and high ph
allows optimal ionization efficiency for
both positive and negative ion modes
the app note below references the best
place to find these detailed methods and
was optimized to separate challenging
isomers of high interest
moving now away from data acquisition
onto software
so we have continued to enhance mass
center profinder feature filing software
which is critical to data analysis
over many years now profinder has been
optimized for both the accuracy of the
feature extraction
as well as the speed profinder uses a
unique recursive analysis approach
across the sample batch in order to
minimize missing features
what i'd like to point out with this
data set is a new chromato-warping
feature
one common problem is the alignment of
features when chromatography is not
completely stable
which is a common phenomenon with all
hillet columns
as you can see here to address this
issue profinder offers flexible
chromatic warping to align the
chromatograms prior to feature
extraction
the results from profinder were easily
exported for subsequent analysis
for this batch we kept only very high
quality features resulting in about 1200
compounds for export
so after importing these compounds into
mvp here again we have the familiar pca
plot and remember we are only working
with the negative eye mode data set with
limited replicates
even so in agreement with the lipid
results here we see a good separation of
the methotrexate treated samples from
the vehicle control
at this point we annotated the compounds
using the id browser tool within mvp
here we chose to search the agilent
metlin pcdl
this pcdl is designed for lcms analysis
and contains
approximately 80 000 compounds including
11 800 metabolites with curated msms
spectra
the agilent metlin pcdl is highly
curated which corrects errors found in
public databases
the ms-ms spectra are also highly
curated to remove noise ensuring only
compound product ions are included
and correcting mrsa values to
theoretical for maximum match quality
the agilent metlin pcdl can be user
customized to add additional compounds
msms spectra and or retention times
we were able to assign pdf annotations
to 690 of the 1188 compounds in the
experiment
so let's get on to some more data
analysis
we can create venn diagrams in mpp in
this case the results are interesting
there are 42 compounds present in the
drug-treated sample but not in the
vehicle control
so from the punitive annotations what
information can we find on the 42
compounds
well one of these was annotated as
deoxyridine monophosphate
inspection of the pro-finder project
shown on the right confirms the absence
and presence of this metabolite into two
groups
now dump was also reported by the paper
we've been referencing as one of the top
four most significant metabolites that
increases with mtx treatment
it turns out there's a good mechanism
for dnp buildup explained by the authors
the enzyme dihydrofolate reductase is
known to be inhibited by methotrexate
this would lead to the reduction of
methylene tetrahydrofolate
methylene tetrahydrofolate serves as the
carbon donor in the conversion of dump
to thymine monophosphate as for the
remaining 41 compounds more work is
needed
we did not see a mass corresponding to
the methotrexate drug itself
but this drug is known to be metabolized
quickly in cells
some of the other compounds could
correspond to drug metabolites including
conjugates
for the remainder of the analysis we
chose to move forward with the
intersection of the 1146 compounds
shared between the two groups
which was really as simple as clicking
on the intersection of the diagram in
mvp and moving forward
so proceeding with that list of features
here on the left we perform
unsupervised higher global clustering
and again the replicas group together
closely
we also see a trend where we see a group
of metabolites highly increased in
methotrexate versus vehicle
on the right a volcano plot shows 93
significant compounds with a fold change
greater than two this also agrees with
the paper where there was a trend that
overall metabolite changes
were greater in magnitude than lipid
differences
at this point to move forward we really
need the msms information
that we are lacking with the substitute
data set we hope to get back in the lab
as soon as possible and acquire this
data
so if you're interested please stay
tuned regarding that progress
one of the prospects we are really
excited about is the ability to
correlate metabolic features with lipid
features
and a multi-omics analysis within npp
here is a proof of principle for the mpp
correlation analysis between the 63
significant lipid features
and 93 metabolite features
clicking on any of these intersections
brings up the correlation plot where one
can observe behavior across replicates
remember in the sample prep we are
extracting both metabolites and lipids
from the same physical sample
with the automated dual metabolic lipid
workflow
so this intra sample analysis would help
to reduce variability compared to the
common strategy where one has to split
the sample for separate types of
extractions
okay wrapping up the metabolite analysis
we finally introduced pathway analysis
so shown here is a cake pathway using
the pathway architect module within mpp
and even with a list of very putative
annotations
we see interesting changes in the
primitive metabolism pathway
zooming in on a particular region we see
significant increases in dump
a metabolite we've already introduced
but we also see corresponding changes in
the neighboring metabolite free
deoxyuridine
together these results agree with the
paper that there is a dysregulation
of nucleotide metabolism
okay to summarize genevieve and i just
presented a comprehensive end-to-end
workflow from sample prep to data
analysis to study cellular metabolism
in the first portion of the talk
genevieve covered a novel method for
room temperature metabolite quenching
optimized for eukaryotic cells the
method is compatible with automation
and enables sequential isolation of both
metabolites and lipids from the same
sample
among other advantages this workflow
should enable direct inter-sample
multi-omics analysis
hopefully i was unable to provide you
with some familiarization of our key
lcms hardware and software including
some new features that enabled an even
more powerful analysis
of molecular changes induced with drug
treatment but i want to end by
mentioning that we just didn't have time
to cover all the products in our
metabolomics portfolio
there's much more beneath the surface to
explore for example
especially with the sample throughput
capabilities we could design large
time-based experiments for qualitative
flux analysis
using vistaflex software we could also
design complementary
experiments with of course our gcms
offerings or look at the cellular buyer
bioenergetics with our seahorse products
so with that genevieve and i would
really like to thank you for your time
today
and invite you to ask any questions you
may have regarding the presentation
all right great thank you both for that
very informative presentation
we're now going to start the q a portion
of the webinar if you still have a
question
you'd like to ask you can still do so
just click on that
ask a question box that's located on the
far left of your screen
okay let's get started the first two
questions i think are
for dr van der bitner bittner
how sticky is trifluoroethanol
does it persist in lcms systems and is
there a washing protocol required
to switch to a different method
yes uh thanks andrea um there are a
couple
ways i'd like to respond to this
particular question um
i guess first i'll mention that in our
method the
tfe is actually dried after
at the end of the method and the
metabolites are reconstituted in a new
solvent
so the tfe is actually not going on the
lcms system
in our particular version of the method
that being said there would actually be
no issue at all with
injecting tfe onto an lcms system
it behaves very similarly to either
ethanol or methanol
it's not sticky at all it can easily be
flushed off of the lclc system
so it's that's not a particular concern
i will mention that i know maybe this
question came up
in thinking about some of the lcms
separation
methods for lc chromatography
in this case there are methods and and
one of the ones i used
to help develop the sample prep method
was the reverse phase ion pairing method
with
a tributal amine and for some of these
ion pairing
methods you do really want to
ideally dedicate an lc to that
particular ion pairing reagent
and you will need to clean the mass spec
before switching to a new method so
there are cases
um where a switch like that might be
necessary um but you wouldn't need to do
it
specifically for triforce ethanol um
if you want more information on cleaning
the mass spec
after using an ion pairing agent like
tba
there is a metabolomic cmrm database and
method
mark was heavily involved in its
development but there is a great
cleaning procedure
outlined in that method
okay great i've got one more for you and
then i'll move over to a couple
uh for dr sartain have you assessed the
extraction efficiency of the capa
plate for a structurally diverse
metabolite and is this data publicly
available
sure that's a great question i think
partly
i'll answer this by going back to some
of the data shared
within this particular talk in our optim
optimization of the water content in
particular
we did look at quite a diver diverse
group of metabolites
that let us know that increasing the
water content of our samples
before they go on the captiva plate
helps with their
recovery from the plate and so we did
have co-a's
as well as nucleic acids organic acids
sugars sugar phosphates where all
amino acids were all included in the
metabolites that we looked at there
so i think we got pretty good coverage
of different metabolite classes
in that case moving to the recovery
experiment
again in this case it's a slightly
smaller group of metabolites we looked
at
that we actually had carbon 13 labels of
and those those metabolites also
included a variety of different classes
from organic acids
nucleic acids sugars and amino acids so
we think there's pretty good coverage
across
metabolite classes for getting good
recovery
from the captiva plate using our method
if you want to see these graphs in
a published form we did have a poster
at asms 2020 so just a couple weeks ago
the poster number is mp3
if you're interested in looking at that
and then you can have the graphs
available to to view as needed
okay great now i'll move over to one
that i believe should be addressed by
dr sartain uh does lipid annotator
accommodate all ions msms data from
q-tops without im
and will that be supported
yeah that's a great question thank you
um so at this time we're not really
supporting i
am percuta sorry all ions for for q talk
without i
am the reason is we don't believe that
gives the best quality data
what we see is that with all ions you
can lose the association of the
fragment ions with the precursor and as
you know many lipids
share common fragment ions across many
different lipids
and so it becomes sort of an analysis
problem where you have a lot of
ambiguity
on you know how confident you are on
your identified lipids
all ions is really useful for eye
mobility where the fragments are
co-aligned with the precursors in terms
of
space and there it has you know some
really some good value
but i personally especially believe that
you know in terms of just q-top mode
only um
isolating the precursor getting exact
mass on the precursor and the fragments
is really the best way to go for more
confident annotations
okay all right great uh one more for you
dr sartain
with data acquisition can you do blank
subtraction with your iterative msms uh
yeah that's that's a great question um
so yes in theory yes you can do blanket
subtraction
and to do this you would have your first
injection and an infidel forklift be
simply a blank sample and then most of
these background molecules will be
selected for msms in that first
injection
and those background precursors will
then be placed on a worlding exclusion
list
and will not be taking your next three
to five injections of your real and
sample
so on the data analysis side you would
only load the iterative data files
corresponding to your real samples
you would leave out the blank you could
you would do it in the loop annotator
and you can theory get a clean analysis
but i would say that while you can do
blank subtraction there are some gotchas
to be aware of
for instance in negative mode i see
traces of ubiquitous and
very common fatty acids probably coming
from mobile phases and surfaces
and these could be excluded from your
analysis and your samples if you find
them in the blank
you may not want to exclude those the
other danger is if
you're in a hurry and you're running
real samples
and you're not monitoring carry over
very well carry over from your
autosample for instance you might see
traces of the most abundant lipids in
your blank from a previous sample
and then you might place those on
exclusion list because you see them in
your blank
and you'd miss those in your analysis
workflow
so i often see you know i think being
overly sophisticated in your iterative
mss setup with
say blank extraction is not always ideal
and i prefer just to put the results
into lipid annotator
and let the software sort out the sort
of the results
okay i'm going to go back over to one
for dr
vanda bittner for the quenching analysis
with carbon 13 labeled glutamine did you
find any carbon-13 labeled metabolites
downstream of glutamate in the tca cycle
right yeah so this is an important
question for answering whether or not
you've really
quenched the samples with the with the
quenching reagents
in this case for unquenched samples we
did find carbon 13 labeled succinate
malate and aspartate from the tca cycle
for the quenched samples so either the
cold quench method
which was done at minus 20 degrees
celsius
or the room temperature tfe quench
samples we did
not actually find any of these carbon 13
labeled
metabolites from the tca cycle um so
again it looks like we were preventing
the conversion of glutamine to glutamate
and then also any conversion downstream
of that
uh in addition to these uh carbon
labeled
studies we did we also tested atp that
was
extracted from the cells and
we found that the atp
level that was extracted from using 50
tfe um did not change if we left the
samples out at room temperature for 24
hours so
this indicates that the atp is very
stable
and that enzymes that would convert atp
into adp or amp are really inactive
in room temperature 50 tfe
okay excellent um back over to dr
sartine
do i have to follow specific
chromatographic conditions for better
results on the lipid annotator
yes great question no you don't you can
use whatever chromatography method you
have and you're happy with
you could use a one minute method a 30
minute method you could use a normal
save reverse
phase it will come you know as long as
you have you know well
good peaks coming out then you can use
whatever you want now once you
build your database and look at
annotator and then you go back to that
profiling method where you're requiring
ms-1 data
you will want to stick with that same
chromatography method because that's
where the retention times
come from that you that you built in
your database okay so you so in that and
that
from that point on your you you should
stick with the same chromatography
after you had the initial database built
okay great and i think we have time for
at least one more
unless there's some more that are going
to be coming in and i think this can go
to either of you
is it best to do iterative msms
injections
at the beginning and end of the run to
have better rt drift correction
yeah i would i would say uh that just
depends on your chromatography and how
much drift you're seeing
with reverse phase lcms on lipids gosh
i'm not seeing
any drift at all so
i typically will put it at the beginning
of the run
but you know you might that might be
something you just want to monitor over
time
and um see what the best strategy you
might see there to see if you do have
any drift
uh then that you got it would make sense
to put it at the beginning at the end
to to later have that data so you could
compare
okay great and actually it looks like we
have time for at least one more
um and i think this one goes to
dr sartain does analyte response
still go down as the acquisition rate
goes up
on the newer 6546 utop
and doesn't that make really high
acquisition rates impractical
so i would say yes it's true that faster
acquisition rates
result in less dwell time for any
particular spectrum and reduced
eye and statistics so as acquisition
rates
go up you'll naturally lose some
sensitivity
so there probably isn't a practical
upper limit on how fast you want to
acquire with your experiment
but that plays a lot into how much
sample you have to work with the irons
you're interested in and
how fast your chromatography is and how
many data points across the peak you
want
in some cases you're going to want to go
fast and i think the point we're trying
to make here is that with qtos
technology you're not limited in how
fast you can go in terms of mass
resolution
you get the same mass resolution at one
hertz or even faster
up to 50 hertz
okay excellent well thank you both again
for your time today and sharing this
important research
do either of you have any final comments
you'd like to make for the audience
yeah i would say that we often get this
question a lot since it wasn't asked
we also get the question of when is this
new sample prep method going to be
available and how do we get it
and we would just say that you know we
made a lot of progress in developing
this method but we currently do not have
plans to release it as a product
but for those labs and you interested in
more details of the manual method
and the automated on the bravo we'd
really be happy to connect with you
directly
um and i also just want to mention that
i said that we were anxious to get you
know back into the lab and complete the
metabolite analysis on the drug treat
cells sure if you're interested in that
story please stay tuned and we hope to
share with you those results in the
future
and really want to thank everyone for
joining us today and thank you for your
time
i hope you're excited as we are about
this new sample prep method
and its real potential and easing the
pain and metabolism research
where sample prep is often a bottleneck
so thank you everybody
great and thank you both again and i'll
echo your thanks to the audience for
joining today and for submitting all of
those interesting questions
for any questions that continue to come
in during the on-demand period or that
we didn't have time for today
they will be addressed by the speakers
using the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june of 2021
but until next time have a great day and
thanks again for joining
you